hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ich glaube jeder von euch kennt
mittlerweile die App be real bei der es
darum geht dass man einmal am Tag eine
Benachrichtigung bekommt und dann muss
man innerhalb von zwei Minuten ein Foto
posten bestehend aus einem Bild von sich
selbst durch die Frontkamera und von dem
was die Rückkamera sieht und nur wenn
man dieses Bild hochlädt kann man auch
sehen was alle deine Freunde in genau
diesem Moment auch auf der Plattform
hochgeladen haben es soll heute
allerdings nicht um die Erklärung dieser
App heute gehen sondern um den Content
den die User der App da so hochladen da
macht nämlich nicht nur jeder irgendwie
so ein Schwachsinns Bild wie ich jetzt
so hey guck mal hier ich sitze am PC
nehme gerade ein Video auf sondern Leute
geben sich da wirklich kreativ Mühe wie
beispielsweise diese Jungs hier
die haben einfach innerhalb von zwei
Minuten eine Entführung dargestellt bei
beereal und wenn ihr euch jetzt
denkt ziemlich zeitaufwendig und blöd
und auch irgendwie holen das alles für
ein be real zu machen schaut euch in mal
an er hat sich mit Kleidung in seine
Badewanne gelegt generell werdet ihr
schon sehen dass die meisten dummen und
witzigen bereil Fotos die ich hier uns
heute rausgesucht habe von Jungs
dargestellt wurden weil ich glaube dass
nur Jungs so dumm sind Mädels haben
irgendwie Hobbys ich meine warum machen
Jungs sowas
warum ist ein Affe mit einer Nerf gun
oder auch beim nächsten be real da haben
wir nämlich einen männlichen Schwimmer
der gerade ein Foto gemacht hat wie er
noch am Rand stand und dann wie er im
Wasser war
also da musst du wirklich erstmal drauf
kommen das nächste Spiel real wird von
einer Person hochgeladen die anscheinend
relativ viele Haustiere hat nämlich auf
jeden Fall zwei Schildkröten und Hund
der den Schildkröten beim Bumsen zuguckt
bei be real ist es generell so dass wenn
ihr euch auf der Plattform befindet die
Bilder so angezeigt werden dass ihr erst
immer ein Foto seht und in dem Foto drin
ist da noch mal als kleines Bild zu
deine Frontkamera deswegen kann man auch
solche Sachen damit machen das grenzt
wirklich schon an Kunst das so genau zu
teilen was auch an Kunst grenzt ist
Make-up beispielsweise als Verkleidung
für einen Clown
ja es ist schon weird wenn man Leuten
sagt können Sie im Büro von mir machen
also ein Foto machen und dann wissen die
gar nicht dass sie sich auch selber
fotografieren hier ist Queen Elizabeth
genau in diesem Moment gestorben über
den Tod von Queen Elizabeth brauchen wir
glaube ich nicht noch weiter reden
das Wort zahlreich getan in den letzten
Wochen allerdings können wir uns
hierüber unterhalten denn die äh naja
Film fotografieren ein ein Huhn was was
kocht man
ekelhaft hier liegt die ganze Clique im
Krankenwagen und das nächste bereel ist
wahrscheinlich danach auch im
Krankenhaus geendet denn da hat sich
eine Person einfach mal Kopf überall
eine Müll
Halde
Container Box reingestellt wie heißt
sowas
Müll Klotz genau machen wir allerdings
weiter mit dem nächsten real und zwar
war dort eine Person im Zoo
hat gefilmt wie Leute mit Krokodilen
Tricks vorführen menschlich gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend hier bekommt eine
Person einen ach komm scheiß auf wir
machen einfach weiter und zwar mit einem
be real wo tatsächlich die Polizei mit
einem bezogen wurde die haben nämlich
die Person abgeschleppt nee abgeführt
keine Ahnung
ihr könnt beide bei mir auch mal auf die
real Folgen ich heiße da Laser Luca 1
weil Laser Luca sich irgendein Idiot
geschnappt hat machen wir allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten be real
und zwar ist das wieder eine typische
Jungs Situation
oder Aktionen oder
auf jeden Fall ist es was typisches was
nur jung sein fallen könnte und zwar das
hier ich kann mir richtig vorstellen wie
sich so gedacht haben hey komm wir
machen die real mach mal Kopfstand das
nächste real wird hochgeladen vom
Designer Friseur
Stylist keine Ahnung was auf jeden Fall
irgendeine Person die anscheinend mit
Kanye West zu tun hat denn er chillt da
einfach mit Kanye West das nächste be
real was ich uns rausgesucht habe ist
tatsächlich mal nicht von Jungs
auch Mädels kommen auf ziemlich dumme
Ideen die dann auch oft die Feuerwehr
mit drin haben die nämlich hier
irgendwie ein Feueralarm hatten und die
kommt als erstes auf die Ideen wie real
zu machen in fun fact übrigens ich war
locker schon also ich war ich bin in
mehr be Reals drin von Leuten die mich
gefragt dann habe ich in deren mit drin
sein kann als ich selber hochgeladen
habe und das ist doch der einzige Grund
warum ich dieses Video hier gerade mache
weil diese App mittlerweile wirklich
diesen diesen Hype Status so ein
bisschen verlassen hat und jetzt
wirklich etabliert ein Social Media
Network ist hier ist eine Person in
einem
wie heißen denn diese noch eine Tiger
nicht ingers Panda nee Löwen nee was ist
ich weiß was ist der Unterschied
zwischen Tiger Panda und Löwe da gibt es
keinen Unterschied machen wir doch
weiter mit dem nächsten be real und zwar
hat dort eine Person gerade einen
verdammten Fallschirmsprung gehabt
oder er hängt dann im Boot mit
irgendeinem Ding das werde ich auch nie
verstehen
wenn man denkt dann sehr wir sind immer
Wasser ist ja nicht so schlimm aber du
hängst an einem Seil
an einem Boot wenn diese Seil reist
knallst du irgendwann auf dem Boden
und dann ist das Wasser genauso hart wie
der Boden hier haben zwei Jungs einfach
ein Loch gebuddelt und sich gedacht
kommen ja lass hier Berühmtheit das sind
alles typische Jungs Aktionen ne es ist
unfassbar was wir für ein dummes
Geschlecht sind sie hatte allerdings auf
jeden Fall gerade ein Autounfall das
erste was sie macht ist wirklich ein
beril machen chillig
deswegen wieso das neue Ding glaube ich
so jemand bricht bei dir ein hey
Einbrecher bevor du gehst können wir
noch kurz die real machen wenn ihr mir
übrigens bei Baby Folgen werdet äh da
wird nichts spannendes geben ich bin
unkreativ und dumm er hier hat die
Unterwäsche von seiner Freundin auf dem
Kopf ich frage mich gar nichts mehr
es sieht doch einfach Loki aus wie
Gurken so ne
[Musik]
nichts vorhin schon ein Autounfall
hatten darf natürlich auch das hier
nicht fehlen einfach an einer verdammten
Klippe dicker ich verstehe aber no joke
auch nicht warum alle diese Leute von
dem wir uns hier heute die witzigen
beril Bilder angucken immer anscheinend
diese notification bekommen haben in dem
Moment wo es richtig krass war
bei mir war das noch nie der Fall aber
bei mir passiert doch generell nichts
krasses im Leben er ist gerade dabei
sein Kaninchen aufzuschlitzen chillig
das ist auf jeden Fall das nächste real
wo sich einfach die Mädels in die
ähm ich habe es auch heute was ist
Regale gelegt mann ey meint mein hier
ist ein Typ gerade am Surfen gewesen und
sein Kollege fällt ins Wasser blöd
gelaufen
machst du nichts
wer im Glashaus sitzt so wo wir
natürlich vorhin schon eine Person
hatten die an so einem komischen Seil an
so einem komischen Boot über so einem
komischen Wasser in so einem komischen
Schirm hängen haben auf jeden
Fallschirmspringer
gut
die kriegen ihre notification wenn sie
gerade einen Fallschirmsprung machen was
man vielleicht einmal in sein verdammten
Leben Mann
ich frage mich wirklich nichts mehr und
bei den Jungs ist wirklich alles schief
gelaufen also ich weiß nicht ob die
wirklich gerade am Fahren sind oder ob
die stehen oder ob er da wirklich aus
dem Fenster hängt oder Superman sein
soll oder sich aus dem Rückspiegel
Fenster da irgendwie raus Rückfahrkamera
ist es eben ja auch wirklich komplett
egal guck mal
ey da wir brauchen hier nicht mehr
weitermachen aber ich habe noch ein paar
und die habe ich nicht umsonst
rausgesucht von der zeige ich euch jetzt
hier einen Typen eingepackt in
Frischhaltefolie mit einem Schrank im
Mund
hätten wir das auch geklärt die Mädels
hier haben einfach mal die halbe
Mikrowelle angezündet indem sie eine
eierpackung angezündet haben und dort
reingestellt haben
wollte im Gegenzug mal meine berials
sehen ich beim Abendessen mit Sandra ich
beim Autofahren mit Sandra ich am Videos
aufnehmen mit Sandra meiner verdammten
Violetts ist mit Sandra und die haben
sogar einen Hund um sowas darzustellen
wie der Hund dann angeblich das Baby
machen würde um sein Futter zu kaufen
wie kommt ihr auf sowas wie habt ihr so
viele Ideen und vor allem so viele
Möglichkeiten was ich habe Gefühl nur
Sandra er ist
ich will hier gar nicht mehr
weitermachen die hier haben einfach auch
ein Überfall dargestellt und eine Oma
anstatt gekriegt und der gerade die
Handtasche geklaut er war gerade mit dem
Scooter unterwegs und kriegt jetzt ein
Ticket von der Polizei aber genau in dem
Moment kriegt er seine Benachrichtigung
und kann was posten genauso wie die
nächste Person die ich euch hier
rausgesucht habe der einfach ein
verdammten gestrandeten Wahl entdeckt
hat
ey mir fällt wirklich nichts mehr ein
hier auch dicker er kriegt genau die
Benachrichtigung bei einem Gewitter und
macht das Foto während genau in diesem
Moment ein
blitzeinkracht und die Sache ist hiervon
ist nichts Fake man kann bei dieser
Plattform nichts faken das sagt ja auch
der Name schon be real
du nimmst das Foto was du machst du
kannst nichts bearbeiten oder oder aus
deiner Galerie nehmen oder es geht nicht
diese Person hat sich gerade die Haare
abgeschnitten und dann ein Foto davon
gemacht Bruder
komm ich zeige euch noch das letzte hat
nämlich eine eine Person einfach in
seine Katze in den Ofen gesetzt und sich
dann gedacht Mensch davon aus jetzt
meinen Freunden gegenüber hey komm gib
mir alle weg bleibt mir gestohlen wenn
ihr Bock habt werdet mich auf die real
ich glaube es gibt ein Freundes Limit
von irgendwie 10000 oder was weiß ich
dann kann ich halt irgendwann keine
Leute mehr annehmen aber wenn ihr euch
diese super tollen Bilder alle paar Tage
von seiner mir angucken wollt dann macht
das